there's another guy i guess who could be
on that list his name's antonio brown he
did not do much last year as
a a supporting member of the the
buccaneers receiving corps
and
this is a strange situation that came to
my attention late last night it was
three weeks ago today
that antonio brown's agent made it known
that he had resigned with the buccaneers
three weeks ago today one day before the
start of the draft antonio brown has
agreed to terms to rejoin the buccaneers
and hey that was the moment they got the
band back together fire the cannons
everything's great we got everyone back
all the starters and the key back up
like antonio brown
so
here we are
and
i i didn't realize we'd never had the
statement from the buccaneers never
antonio brown has resigned he's not on
the roster of the tampa bay buccaneers
bruce arians coach of the buccaneers
appearing on the pewter report podcast
addressed the fact that antonio brown
remains not an official member of the
buccaneers here's ariens
ellie has to pass the physical and uh
you know he he
hopefully
uh will have a scope on tuesday getting
his knee cleaned up and and everything
will work out fine we wanted to be back
and he was a model citizen the whole
time he's been here and uh we wanted him
back and he's never had surgery in his
life so uh so it's just a matter of
getting the physical done
and
so yeah no i've wanted him back the
whole time
look that's fine
okay when you hear it when you read it
okay no big deal but when you think
about it
what the hell's going on
he's getting knee surgery yesterday
may 18th he's getting knee surgery is
this surgery from the knee injury that
knocked him out of part of the playoffs
he did play in the super bowl he didn't
play in the nfc championship is this
some knee injury that happened after the
fact has he already had a physical that
he failed that resulted in him going to
get
the knee surgery there's a lot there
chris
and other than last year when the
pandemic dramatically complicated the
ability of guys to get physicals done
because you couldn't physically go get
your physical
this never happens where you have a
three-week lag
between
hey we got antonio brown
and oh wait he still has to pass a
physical
i i i
just shrug at it but i think there's
something more there potentially i think
it'd be foolish
not to ask what the hell's going on i i
agree i mean you know your example is
odd okay the you know in the nfl it like
this doesn't happen you know what you
said or even
hey we're agreeing to terms and then
we're going to do the physical and go
through things like that you know i just
feel like that's odd too oh that we're
going to take a look at it there's a
knee problem hey we're going to sign you
back now let's take a look at your knee
and do all that stuff
that to me is odd how the whole thing
kind of shakes out there it definitely
does i don't i don't know i don't know
and yeah i guess it's i guess i also
think about you know the recent off the
field stuff does that play into it i
mean of course that always comes up when
you think about antonio brown and all
that that you know process uh so yeah
it's kind of one of those mic where i i
think i'm gonna be like you i'm gonna
question it a little bit until
i see it and then i'll totally believe
it here because again they are
stacked at wide receiver as well and
it's not like he's a necessity i know
he's still really good but he's not a
necessity and i just i wonder maybe if
they're having second thoughts or
something like that
it's not uncommon for the physical to
follow agreeing to terms it is uncommon
for it to follow by three weeks that's
very yeah right right usually it is done
bang bang you'll see the report one day
of the looming signing and then the next
day comes the official statement from
the team that so and so has signed a
contract three weeks is odd unusual i
don't want to say unprecedented because
then i'd have to research and see is
there some situation in the past where
there's been a delay other than last
year when for multiple players there
were protracted delays remember the todd
gurley deal in atlanta yeah it took
weeks and weeks because of the pandemic
here's my theory chris and i don't think
this is
high level
short sleeve dress shirt red yarn
everywhere conspiracy theory i think
this is fairly obvious when you consider
the broader circumstances
when was this announced by his agent it
was announced the day before the draft
began right so
other teams see that oh they got antonio
brown back well they're not a team that
we are flagging as a team that may draft
wait for it
a receiver
and in round four what did the
buccaneers do they took north texas
receiver jalen darden who came out
fairly high in the pic
process last year tyler johnson from
minnesota who came in and had a great
impact especially in the post season
made some big catches there oh and they
still have scotty miller oh and they've
got chris godwin oh and they've got mike
evans look
there's a chance that antonio brown's
already served his purpose for the 2021
buccaneers there's a chance that this
deal isn't getting done and announcing
it the day before the draft was all
about providing cover so when they take
jail and darden
no one else is watching lower on the
board saying we better jump them if we
want jail jalen darden if you're
watching the bucks in round four you're
thinking oh they got antonio brown and
and again this is not next level
conspiracy stuff this is just the
gamesmanship that happens during the
draft and the fact that it was announced
unofficially the day before the draft
began you can't rule out the possibility
that the bucks knew damn well what they
were doing in striking that deal
pending a physical yeah i you you might
be right mike and oddly enough really
it's a guy that plays a position that's
similar to antonia brown and has kind of
a similar skill set i mean the dude a
durden out of north texas can really fly
i mean really fly he's like you know
it's it's tyree kill
three rockets up your butt type of speed
mike that's what we're talking about
he's a real weapon so i don't know the
fact that yeah maybe that was the plan
or they didn't expect him on the board
and then he you know whoa he's there
still all right we gotta take them does
that affect you know now going forward
going well maybe we don't need to resign
antonio we got a guy that we didn't
really think would be there in round
four i think there's a lot of different
possibilities and you know even mike
just one thing i wanted to clean up from
my own personal uh speaking you're right
i know most guys you know you do the
contract and then you get the physical
laughter what's odd is not it doesn't go
down like that when you're signing with
the team you were already on that's
where i should have been clear it's what
usually when you even when you're going
to be a free agent and you're going to
re-sign with that team that team has
been keeping up with you medically
because of after the year we check the
knee we do those things usually you end
up getting surgery by that type of team
and then they start going hey yeah we're
going to resign you let's do one more
checkup after we sign you on the need to
make sure it's okay that's where i i
misspoke and maybe didn't explain that
clearly well and and i think this is
what you're getting at right
don't they give every player whether
he's going to be a free agent or not an
exit physical all the way out the door
exactly yes right and you can usually
hear anything about antonio brown
failing that nothing and usually if a
player has an issue he makes it very
vocal right away at the end of the year
because he wants it the nfl pa everybody
you know all the the the the paper
trails that keep track of your medical
issues for after football anything like
that or just to get the problem fixed
right away you tell the team you know my
knee's been bothering me you know maybe
can we go you know look at it get an mri
it's been bothering me for a while and
then that starts the process of okay
let's fix it that's why it's just weird
that it's happening now and we're gonna
sign them but we didn't sign them and
now we're going to have a surgery and
look at his knee and clean them up i
mean i'm with you i just think it's an
odd way to do business in the nfl
questions that arise did he pass the
exit physical if he did what happened
between then and now did he already take
a physical
in connection with signing this one-year
deal to stay with the buccaneers and did
he fail at necessitating the surgery
it's entirely possible he suffered a new
injury since the end of the season maybe
he thought the knee was fine exit
physical past and then he starts working
out i mean the guy's going to be 33 on
you yeah
right so and he's never had surgery well
he may have all sorts of stuff floating
around in those knees that may be
affecting his ability to run like he
used to so these are all fair questions
and by the way one last thing yeah about
the fourth round pick that was spent on
a receiver they traded up the buccaneers
did they traded up they were getting
nervous that the guy they wanted wasn't
gonna be there so that feeds into the
idea that there was a little bit of
gamesmanship going on in making it known
to the world that antonio brown is going
to be back just before the draft begins
that gives you that layer of cover so
you can go get that receiver you may be
targeting in the mid rounds of the draft
and do they really need antonio brown at
this point
not really they don't bro bruce aaron's
made this point hey hey that's sixth
spot on game day
who that's going to be very competitive
yeah who's going
evans godwin brown miller johnson and
now you got the rookie the fourth round
they traded up for they gave up a
six-round compensatory pick to move up
along with the fourth round pick that
they already had you think they're gonna
cut that guy no way no way he'd have to
have the absolute like worst camp you
could absolutely have to get cut in the
fourth round for a guy that traded up
he'd have to really like fall flat on
his face yeah i mean mike i'm i'm with
you when you put it out like that it it
almost like
kind of seems like what are they really
going to sign them does that even make
sense so
i don't know bruce doesn't bs much we
know that so i'm going to take him at
his word it's tommy's boy and antonio
brown
he is a veteran who can do a lot of
different things and you could throw a
lot on them you know even like this play
we're showing here that was i think uh a
little bit of a a route where
he had to read the coverage and that's
where like brady wants antonio brown
like hey you got to be on the same page
as me we this is this is a different
kind of play it's not just like hey i
call a slant it's like i want a slain if
the guy's on the outside if the guy cuts
you off on this land i want you to work
the slant and then come back out right
it's those type of things and i think
that's where brady's going to continue
to
pound the table for a guy like antonio
brown because he can do some of that
julian edelman wes welker stuff and
brady can have his trust there
but you know i want to bring up a point
and and i i pissed some people off sorry
manchester a couple of weeks ago when i
dusted off well i wasn't the one who
dusted it off nick saban's the one who
dusted off the fact that the dolphins
could have had drew brees but it was the
doctors who said they can't sign drew
brees and my point was if nick saban's
really in charge of the football
operation and he wants drew brees he
keeps asking doctors for opinions until
he finds one who says go ahead and sign
drew brees because oh wait the saints
did
hey
maybe the maybe the bucks
have decided the way they're going to
deal with tommy on this is say sorry he
just can't pass the physical well we
want him you want him we all want him we
he just can't pass a physical now
brady's been around long enough to see
through that
bs right but that's an easy way chris
you're not saying to tommy you can't
have you can't have your buddy on the
team this year you're just gonna have to
settle for gronk and maybe julian
edelman if his knee recovers but but you
can't have antonio brown because the
doctors won't let us sign him i'd love
to sign him i want him here that's why
bruce arians maybe says what he says
hey hey
all he's got to do is pass the physical
all he's got to do is pass the physical
oh
oh wait he didn't oh oh we went in there
and sculpted it didn't look good it's
not it's
yeah it's not what we thought okay yeah
no you're right that's that would be the
great way to to escape the situation
and i i don't know i mean
i i was
like shocked by this yesterday because i
was just like damn you know what you're
right we never really got an official
signing it kind of just we just took it
for granted and moved on
and now it's got me thinking and now i'm
to the point where it's like i gotta see
it to believe it here over the next few
days to really think he's gonna be back
and it is it is funny when you read the
story that was posted by the pewter
report website it it buys in completely
and totally
to aryan's downplaying and i think
that's part of the price you pay
sometimes for access because i think the
last thing that they want to do is call
bs on bruce arians after they just got
him on the podcast right right and
they're going to say hey this guy's
telling us something that may not be
yeah right come back again bruce
leave that to us pewter report we got
you covered here i i think because it's
funny
they posted the tweet
with their story and they tagged me they
tagged the pft account on twitter that's
how i became aware of it and i saw it i
had the same reaction you did what the
hell is this yeah oh yeah he hasn't
officially been announced right so
i think sometimes when your gut tells
you something's going on there's a
reason for that yeah something's going
on i agree and you've got as good a good
as anybody nobody's got better pasta and
meatballs than you in there
and here's what i'm gonna do after the
show or maybe during one of the breaks
if i think of it i'm gonna ask the
buccaneers did he pass his exit physical
and has he already taken a physical and
failed it yeah uh and uh we'll see what
they say maybe they'll answer it maybe
they won't but whatever they say is
going to be instructive on where this
thing potentially happened
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports